if you would like to excuse me your
chance to win a copy of Infiniti award
the art of the movie art book a copy of
Avengers infinity war Deadpool 2 or
ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts
and your favorite superhero we all know
wife anna's collected the Infinity
stones performed the snap and wiped out
half of the beans in the universe from
existence
Thanos set out to balance the universe
after his own people on his home planet
of Titan became extinct but fan o's did
not set out to collect the Infinity
stones at first he set out to balance
the universe by himself so what did
dannis do before going after the
Infinity stones when Thanos was still
living on Titan it was a very
overpopulated planet with not enough
resources to go around
Thanos made the recommendation that they
exterminate half of the population
randomly in order to save the rest of
the population of course they said no
called him a madman and exiled him so
after he was exiled the planet ended up
dying along with all the people on the
planet leaving Thanos as the last Titan
Thanos feared that the rest of the
universe would suffer the same fate of
his home planet of Titan so Thanos took
it upon himself to save the universe by
balancing it going planet by playing it
throughout the universe and wiping out
half of the population of each planet as
a way to correct the planet and bring it
back into balance the race that lived on
Titan were the Eternals the Eternals
were created by the Celestials and have
super godlike powers afterthe anos left
titan he went into deep space and took
control of an asteroid field from a race
known as the Chitauri the Chitauri swore
their loyalty to Thanos making him the
leader of their army
Thanos would also later become the
leader of the outrider army as well
Thanos with his two armies went planet
to planet and would personally wipe out
half of each planet's population from
existence
Estados went planet to planet
exterminating half of the population he
would collect children that became
orphans due to the extermination this
included Gamora
and nebula his oldest children were
Corvus glaive evany mal call obsidian
and Proxima midnight all were extremely
and completely faithful and devoted to
Thanos the four of them would be known
as the Black Order Thanos along with the
black order that Atari and the out
writers continued to go planet to planet
wiping out half of the populations in
existence
Thanos eventually realized that there
were far too many life forms in the
universe to balance but once he learned
about the Infinity stones he realized
that that was his way to balance and
control the whole entire universe once
Thanos learns that he could control the
entire universe with all of the Infinity
stones he makes it his life goal to
collect them he even gets some allies to
help him in his quest such as Loki and
Ronan the accuser just to name a few
eventually Thanos would go on to collect
all of the Infinity stones and snap away
half of the universe which we all saw in
Avengers infinity war so that's what
Thanos did before he collected all the
Infinity stones do you think that the
Avengers will somehow find a way to take
back all of the Infinity stones from
Thanos and Avengers 4 or do you think
they'll defeat him in some other way let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to marvel and
Avengers for as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]